maybe you feel that European
institutions are far removed from your
everyday life well in fact the European
Parliament is much closer to home than
you could ever have imagined it's
present in all Member States through its
information offices even in Washington
DC these information officers are the
go-to places for answers in your own
language on the role and activities of
the European Parliament and its members
as well as all EU policies they also
provide free information material
organised debates with MEP s and stake
holders and keep the media informed as
news from the Parliament through press
briefings information officers work
closely with teachers and schools to
make the European Parliament accessible
and comprehensible to young people
through seminars and debates designed
especially for them they also organize a
competition called Euro Scholar that
gives students from all Member States if
selected the chance to become an MEP for
a day at the Parliament seat in
Strasbourg in France to keep their
finger on the pulse of citizens need for
up-to-date news and information
information officers are in touch with
many different professional groups local
authorities companies non-government
organizations and anyone else who has an
interest in European affairs and the
role of the European Parliament so where
is your nearest information point to
find it all you have to do is to type
European Parliament information office
in your browser and it'll all appear
before your very eyes oh and one more
thing we'll forget to follow them on
social media too